okie-dokie um I apologize for beginning
the show by saying okey-dokey
that but we can't go back now they can't
undo it it happened and we now both have
to live with that alright so moving past
that what's the latest fake stupid
controversy that we can waste our time
talking about for that we go to Ken
Cuccinelli who is one of the one of
trumps top immigration officials a
little background here before we get to
the to the fakes too big controversy a
little background recently it was
announced in the past couple of days it
was announced by the Trump
administration that they would be taking
steps to better enforce public charge
policies now these are policies that
Trump did not invent they don't
originate with him nobody in the
administration came up with this these
are policies that have existed in some
form or another for a hundred years it's
just that they haven't been enforced
very well or at all and what the Trump
administration is saying is hey let's
let's actually enforce these laws the
idea behind public charge policies is
that we you know we don't generally want
to accept immigrants into the country
even legally who are or are likely to be
on public assistance in other words we
don't want to bring people here just so
that they can live off of the taxpayers
who are already living here why don't we
want that well because we can't afford
it for one thing our nation is already
famously in a lot of debt and we just we
can't keep adding to it a certain point
you have to you have to cut it off and
it's not fair to the taxpayers the
taxpayers have their own families to
take care of first and foremost and so
to keep adding more and more people from
all across the world say yeah take care
of them too and then and then and then
it as I said we got to cut it off
somewhere and there's no real benefits
to the nation or to society to our
society immigration should not be a
one-way street it's always been the idea
has always been you benefit because you
get to come here and we benefit because
because you come here it should be a
two-way beneficial arrangement and it's
not if you're just coming here to live
off of us and we want people motivated
by a desire to come
contribute not to come and exploit the
system so it makes a lot of sense a lot
of sense to encourage immigrants who
will be able to care for themselves and
to discourage immigrants who are not
able to care for themselves or are not
interested in caring for themselves
America is not a giant daycare center
it's not a big a big boarding school
it's a it's a country and country's only
function when people are caring for
themselves and standing on their own two
feet now we do have things like soup
kitchens in America which is great but
America itself is not a soup kitchen and
it can't be one and that goes for every
other country on Earth the only
difference is for every other country on
it well I should say every other
non-western non predominantly white
country it's understood that they they
have the same attitude about immigrants
sometimes in many cases they have much
harsher attitudes towards immigrants and
nobody criticizes that now everyone
everyone understands hey it's your
country do what you want it's only with
our country that well we're not allowed
to see it as our country it's not ours
so we just have to throw the doors open
to anybody wants to come well Cuccinelli
was on NPR talking about this perfectly
logical logical unassailably sensible
policy when he was asked how this policy
squares with the poem on the Statue of
Liberty of course this is irrelevant
anyway we don't make laws based on
poetry the you know the Fish and
Wildlife Service
it doesn't make its laws based on what
it says and I don't know the Raven by
Edgar Allan Poe it's that's not
individuals may be inspired by poetry
but that's not how we make laws the poem
on the Statue is not a law but he was
asked about it anyway and and so we'll
play this is from NPR this is how that
little little conversation went watch
this would you also agree that Emma
Lazarus's words etched on the Statue of
Liberty give me your tired your poor are
also part of the American ethos they
certainly are give me your tired and
your poor
can stand on their own two feet and who
will not become a public charge that
that plaque was put on the Statue of
Liberty at almost the same time as the
first public charge law was passed very
interesting timing although you
mentioned the American Dream is is built
on this idea that this is a place where
you can come and build early ok so
what's his point well it's pretty
obvious he's simply saying that this
policy of looking for immigrants who can
contribute rather than ones who will
drain our resources and give nothing in
return
is in fact perfectly consistent with the
poem not that once again not that it
really matters but it is consistent with
what the poem says that's that's that's
his argument anyway that's what he's
trying to say well then what happened
after Cuccinelli was asked about the
poem remember he didn't bring it up he
didn't come in and say hey listen you
know I've been thinking about this
poetry and his poem and I know he he was
asked about it he answered the question
well then the media headlines start
pouring in let me read a couple
headlines these are headlines referring
to that little tidbit you just listen to
from CNN Cuccinelli rewrites Statue of
Liberty poem to make case for limiting
immigration Politico Trump immigration
official offers a rewrite for Statue of
Liberty poem Washington Post historians
bash Ken Cuccinelli's revised Statue of
Liberty poem Time magazine trump
immigration Hedrick trump immigration
head rewrites iconic Statue of Liberty
poem to justify new immigration
restrictions and so on this is I feel
like a broken record but this is just
utterly utterly dishonest and fraudulent
the media is lying as usual this this is
fake news there it is there's total fake
news he didn't rewrite anything and he
isn't the one who brought it up he was
asked a question and he answered it it
this is one of the most this is one of
the pettiest little tricks that the
media pulls and you got to watch out for
this because they
this all the time this is one of their
favorite things to do and a lot of times
people miss it what they do is they ask
somebody a weird and irrelevant question
that person answers the question and
then they report the answer to the
question as if that person had brought
it up on his own
unprompted so based on those headlines
or those headlines are wrong number one
because he didn't rewrite anything
there's no rewrite based on the headline
you would think even in know any better
that he literally rewrote it and they're
gonna they're gonna you know attach that
to the Statue of Liberty instead he
didn't rewrite anything so that's not
true
but you would also think based on the
headline and the way these these stories
are framed that you know he had this
idea on his own and then he went to the
media and said hey I've been thinking
about the Statue of Liberty poem here's
my thought no he was asked about in any
answer so it'd be like if the media
asked me if they came to me and they
said Matt Walsh if you had to choose
would you bash a baby kangaroo to death
with a shovel or would you drown an old
lake old lady in the ocean and then I
said I mean I guess I would if I had to
choose I guess I'd bash the kangaroo but
and then the headline is Matt Walsh goes
on unhedged rant fantasizes about
bashing baby kangaroos to death with a
shovel it's such a lame move but it
works it works on people who are too
dumb or too lazy to read past a headline
or sometimes even to read in between the
lines which is what you need to do and
we're not done yet okay so that's it
that's just how the day started with
with cuccinelli making this point and
then being and then being disingenuously
intentionally misinterpreted
mistranslated Cuccinelli then goes on
CNN to talk about this little dust-up
and to clarify you know what he actually
meant and so let's watch how that went
you say this is about self-sufficiency
and you say that proudly you heard me to
play you this morning when you quoted
the Emma Lazarus poem on the Statue I
wasn't quoting it I was answering a
question right okay I'm sorry but you
were giving your version of what you
thought the poem should say right no no
I was not you said
give me your tires and I'm not rewriting
poetry okay well what you said is give
me your tired and your poor who can
stand on their own two feet and who will
not become a public charge I just played
you sang it right I listen okay I'm
making sure not just being said okay so
obviously the actual poem is quite
different
I'm gonna read right I was answering a
question I wasn't writing poetry Aaron
don't don't change the fact I'm not
twisting this like everybody else you're
saying that it's very important to be
able to stand on your own two feet a lot
of people may so or respect you're
saying that but the poem doesn't say
that right the poem by authority I
didn't bring up the poem what you an NPR
reporter did and now you have I didn't
bring it up I'll answer your substantive
intelligence okay okay stop there for
just a minute I have to say that that
this isn't really the point but I have
to say I kind of love this guy because
he's really calm he's collected while
calling her out on her bullcrap at the
same time which is exact was great
that's exactly what needs to be done and
where he says you know I'll answer your
subjective and intelligent questions
please ask one that's that's see this is
exactly this is a this is like a
training manual for how to deal with
these hacks in the media but let's go
let's get let's get to the pointer let's
go back to the back to the clip however
it came up you said give me your tired
and your poor okay who can stand on
their own two feet and he will not
become a public charge that's what
you're saying I just played it the poem
reads give me your tired your poor your
huddled masses yearning to breathe free
the wretched refuse of the teeming Shore
send these the homeless tempest-tossed
to me I lift my lamp beside the Golden
Door wretched poor refuse right that's
what the poem says America is supposed
to stand for so what do you think
America stands for well of course that
poem was referring back to people coming
from Europe where they had class-based
societies where people were considered
wretched if they weren't in the right
class and it was introduced it was
written one year one year after the
first federal public charge rule was
written that says and I'll quote it any
person unable to take care of
self without becoming a public charge
unquote would be inadmissible or in the
terms that my agency deals with they
can't do what's called adjusting status
getting a green card becoming legal
permanent residents same exact time Eryn
same exact time in the year it went on
the Statue of Liberty 1903 another
federal law was passed expanding the
elements of public charge by Congress
okay we can cut it there because then
erin burnett goes into some irrelevant
story about her grandfather coming to
this country or whatever
can i just say as a side note i'm so
tired of people doing this with the
immigration thing you know it's yeah we
get it everybody's grandparents came
here and you know i'm sure that they
blob so on and so I mean I'm not I'm not
trying to diminish what your
grandparents did or the struggles ahead
but can we just every conversation about
immigration turns into it well it turns
into something you're spinning some yarn
about your grandparents coming over here
it's not relegate good for you which is
what does that have to do with anything
it has nothing to do with anything
but that's that's how she wastes the the
remaining minutes of this of this
interview talking about her grandparents
who cares no offense who cares
but you notice what Cuccinelli said
they're in an effort to explain why the
Statue of Liberty has that language
about wretched refuse which is pretty
harsh language actually and it makes you
it makes you wonder why liberals love
this poem so much they were referring to
immigrants as wretched to refuse that's
calling them trash basically that's what
it is refuse is trash
wretched garbage is what this poem
refers to immigrants as I mean can you
only imagine if Trump if Trump were to
even quote the poem if Trump were to
quote that poem the headline would be
President Trump calls immigrants
wretched garbage but in an effort to
explain why that language is in there
what that is referred to where that
comes from
an effort to explain that he says that
it refers to the class-based societies
of Europe
the language comes from so then what are
the headlines about this interview USA
Today
immigration official Ken Cuccinelli
Statue of Liberty poem refers to
immigrants from Europe another headline
statue of Cucinelli Statue of Liberty
poem refers to people from Europe
Huffington Post Ken Cuccinelli Statue of
Liberty poem about about people coming
from Europe and then subtitle you know
the sub-header trump citizenship and
immigration chief followed up his
earlier comments about the famous Emma
Lazarus poem with a racist clarification
oh my gosh these people these are such
dishonest acts it's amazing it's amazing
that a person can be this dishonest like
when you're when you're writing that
headline you know that you're lying
you know what you're doing don't you
ever catch a glimpse of yourself a
reflection of yourself maybe in a you
know in a you know in the rear view
mirror on occasion and just stop and say
what am i what kind of person in my that
I'm doing this this is what I do I just
slander people with with dishonest
headlines obviously and the Huffington
Post was pretty explicit about it these
other headlines though and there were
you know dozens of them across
mainstream media saying that Ken
Cuccinelli claimed that the Statue of
Liberty poem refers to immigrants from
Europe well yes that is what he said but
obviously the implication which having a
post made clear what they're trying to
imply is that Cuccinelli was saying that
only European immigrants are welcome
which isn't what he was saying he was
trying to explain why that kind of
language is in there which derives from
the bigoted class-based societies of
Europe now as for the poem itself is our
immigration policy including you know
this stuff about public charges does it
conflict with the poem again for the
fourth time it doesn't matter because we
don't make laws by engraving them in
bronze and putting them on a statue that
would be a pretty interesting
legislative system we
I am the theocratic dictator of of the
hemisphere it it I that's probably how
I'll will will make laws but the thing
is no one else it's just me I can I'll
engrave things in stone put them on a
statue of myself and probably in every
in every town there will be big statues
of me holding you know the the tablet
with all the laws and there'll be a lot
of laws a lot of law so we're gonna keep
adding to it Nana too so that's gonna be
the legislative process for me but that
but right now that's not how it works we
have a legislative branch of government
they have a process by which bills
become law you can watch the schoolhouse
rocks video if you want clarification on
that so it's it has no this has no
bearing on anything but with that said
if we want to say that well the poem is
much like the Declaration of
Independence the Declaration of
Independence is not law either but it is
a poetic document sort of talking about
the philosophies that underpin the
American system and so it's sort of
aspirational in that way talking about
what we aspire to and so you can make
the same case as the poem is it yeah
it's not a law but it's kind of like
that's that's the that's how America's
basically that's our philosophy that's
what our philosophy is supposed to be
okay fine well let's look here's the
full poem okay here's the full poem with
both both verses he says not like the
brazen giant of Greek fame with
conquering limbs astride from land to
land here at our sea-washed sunset gates
shall stand a mighty woman with a torch
whose flame is the imprisoned lightning
and her name mother of exiles from her
beacon hand glows worldwide welcome her
mild eyes command the air bridged Harbor
that Twin Cities frame keep ancient
lands your storied pomp cry she with
silent lips give me your tired your poor
your huddled masses yearning to breathe
free the wretched refuse of your teeming
Shore send these the homeless
tempest-tossed to me I lift my lamp
beside the Golden Door okay it's a
beautiful poem nobody no I think it's a
beautiful poem I don't think anyone
denies
and as Americans that we could be proud
of that but the reason I read the full
poem notice something in the poem it
says give me your tired your poor your
huddled masses yearning to breathe free
so there is sort of a qualifier and
there isn't in there isn't there it's
not just hey you know it dump all the
wretched refuse on our Shore know it
give us those who yearn for freedom and
I totally agree that's exactly who we
want those are exactly the sorts of
immigrants that we want those who yearn
for freedom those are the kinds of
citizens we want even if they were born
in this country as far as I'm concerned
even if you were born here and you don't
want freedom we don't need you I wish
you would leave okay you're you you
you're not helping you should go to it
free dumb isn't what you want then I
think this country isn't for you you
should seriously leave and go somewhere
else well it and that's the point we're
looking for people who are yearning to
breathe free yearning for freedom how
does this relate to the whole public
charge thing well if you're coming here
with the primary intention of living off
of the government and being on these
social welfare programs and being a
charge of the government then you're not
yearning for freedom what you want is
actually the opposite of freedom and
that's really the main problem even
aside from the financial burden of
having to care for all of these people
from all across the globe
I'm aside from that it's just sort of
philosophically it shows that someone
comes here for that purpose they they're
not buying in to the American idea and
that's the biggest problem I think we
want everyone who comes here and
everybody lives here we all need to buy
into the to the basic American idea we
could we can disagree in so many other
ways and that's great but the basic
principles and the most basic
of all is that of liberty and freedom if
you're not buying into that then then
this country is not for you and that
should be our message and again if
you're coming here because you want to
live off the government that's not
freedom so I think Cucinelli had it
exactly right
okay let's moving on here there's a
prominent Harvard professor named
Lawrence tribe who maybe you've heard of
he recently attempted he sent out a
tweet where he attempted to draw a
connection between the pro-life movement
and white supremacy and he's not the
first leftist to try to pull this move
it's pretty common especially recently
but in a tweet that he posted on Sunday
said white supremacist oppose abortion
because they fear it'll reduce the
number of white infants and thus
contribute to what they fear as
non-white replacement never
underestimate the way these issues and
agendas are linked this turns
intersectionality on its head now I
wanted to address this because you'll
notice that abortion advocates
frequently this is what they do they
malign the alleged motives of pro-lifers
rather than engaging with the actual
arguments that pro-lifers are making
that's because the pro-life argument
which very simply is that human babies
are human and thus directly killing them
is murder and because it directly
intentionally killing any innocent human
life is murder that's our argument right
there it is logically morally and
scientifically airtight to defeat it you
have to either argue that humans aren't
always human which science disproves
or you have to argue that intentionally
killing an innocent human isn't always
murder which is morally abominable which
up whichever option you choose you're
walking out on to a very precarious limb
and I think it's it's therefore it's
much easier for abortion proponents to
forego arguments altogether and to
simply declare that pro-lifers really
hate women or they really hate poor
people or according to tribes variation
of the theme they really hate black
people this is an easy claim to make but
it is unfortunately an exceedingly
stupid one as well and so I just want to
for a moment reflect on the
stupidity of this claim first of all it
should be noted that avowed white
supremacists are famously pro-abortion
okay you among white supremacist white
nationalists whatever they are not
people who are feel passionately
pro-life it's quite the opposite and as
someone who myself has been labeled a
cuck Servet of by many an alt right
person for my pro-life advocacy I can
personally attest to this I have I have
encountered this argument from that
crowd many times I mean at at most among
white supremacist what you're gonna hear
is well abortions irrelevant we should
be talking about it that's that's that's
like that's the most pro-life they'll
get but very often in fact they'll be
they will be explicitly pro-abortion
Richard Spencer has endorsed abortion
arguing that quote smart people use it
to get rid of you know Down syndrome
babies or to protect the life of the
mother and in that way his his argument
for abortion is pretty indistinguishable
from just the standard leftist argument
for abortion and he has explicitly
disavowed the pro-life movement and has
told his supporters to be suspicious of
anyone affiliated with it again
indistinguishable rhetoric from what
leftist Pro aborts say it's not
difficult to see why white supremacist
would support rather than oppose the
practice of murdering children in the
womb black babies comprise a grossly
disproportionate number of abortion
victims in this country black people
make up only about 13% of the overall
population yet they account for close to
40% of all abortions in some in some
major US cities okay
black children are more likely to be
aborted than born that's that's how
that's that's the way this is working
out now a white supremacist may
not prefer to see white babies aborted
but he will certainly support legalized
abortion because he knows that the black
population would be significantly larger
today if not for the work of Planned
Parenthood and its ilk more more black
people have died by abortion than by
cancer heart disease accidents violent
crime combined why would a white
supremacist want to give up a tool as
potent as that he wouldn't now speaking
of Planned Parenthood its founder
Margaret Sanger was a passionate
eugenicist as I think most most informed
people know she once presented her ideas
at a Klan meeting there's a there's a
picture floating around out there at
Margaret Sanger speaking to a Klan
meeting that picture is fake it's a
Photoshop but she did speak to a
playmate just that there's no picture of
it but she did in fact so what it's
depicting is true but the pictures faked
historically Planned Parenthood has been
has been quite open about its real
intentions it's only in recent years
that they've gotten shy about their goal
of exterminating society's supposed
undesirables in 1969 a lot of people
don't know about this even pro-lifers
the vice president of Planned Parenthood
Frederick J's in 1969 produced in a memo
called the jafe memo outlining his
organization's long-term goals he was he
was asked by the government to come up
with a way of limiting the population
and and you know staving off the
supposed overpopulation crisis which is
a myth but the government at the time
was wanted to do that and they knew they
knew who to talk to you talked to
Planned Parenthood and so Planned
Parenthood came up with this with this
memo suggesting some things that should
be done these things include reduce
slash eliminate paid maternity leave
compulsory compulsory sterilization
compulsory abortion of out of wedlock
pregnancies limit slash eliminate
public finance medical care scholarships
housing loans housing and loans for
families who have too many children and
it goes on from there
now the Jake memo doesn't specifically
mention black people or racial
minorities but the goal is very clear to
reduce the population of the poor and
economically disadvantaged by any means
necessary
and it just so happens that a
disproportionate number of people who
are poor and economically disadvantaged
are black so on this point as on so many
others white supremacists are in
substantial agreement with Planned
Parenthood and with the abortion
industry and it should also be noted
that Geoff's and Margaret Sanger's plans
have been carried out with great success
by the abortion industry in that you
know over half of all abortions are had
by by by people who are you know below
the poverty line or near the poverty
line at least so to support abortion
here I think this is what it comes down
to in order to support abortion you must
see life on a hierarchy where some life
is less important and more expendable
than others that's the only way to
support abortion it has to in some way
be based on that idea that not all life
is equal some life is less important
more expendable especially if it's
dependent and and weak and and
vulnerable then then it's going to be
especially expendable now it just so
happens again
that's exactly how racists see the world
which is why racism and abortion have
always fit together so perfectly to
oppose abortion on the other hand you
have to see life as possessing inherent
Worth and dignity that's really the only
reason to oppose abortion and it's a
pretty good reason you have to see that
life is inherently valuable but a
recognition of all human life is
inherently valuable having inherent
Worth and dignity is not a good place to
start if you want to be an effective
race
that's racist that's not the view that
racists are gonna have and that's why
this idea that there's any relationship
at all between whites of so-called white
supremacy and racism and and you know
pro-life advocacy is just it could not
be more wrong these are literally two
opposite views of the world all right
before we get to emails
let's check in briefly with with Jeffrey
Epstein and I haven't even I just saw
this article on The Daily wire haven't
even read it myself yet but just quick
quick quick details on this the report
of The Daily wire says the two prison
guards in charge of monitoring convicted
pedophile and alleged sex trafficker
Jeffrey Epstein on the morning that he
committed suicide reportedly fell asleep
did not check on him for hours and then
falsified prison records to hide their
actions the new developments in the
investigation into epstein suicide come
after the just Department announced on
Tuesday that the two guards have been
placed on administrative leave and the
warden of the prison was being
temporarily reassigned the New York
Times reports the two correctional
officers in the housing unit where mr.
Epstein was held 9 South is the housing
unit falsely recorded in a log that they
had checked on the financier who was
facing sex trafficking charges every 30
minutes as was required but they lied
such false entries in an official log
could constitute a federal crime alright
so that's the latest we've got these
people you're the people surrounding
this issue are being sent away and now
we're told that the two prison guards
simultaneously fellas they both fell
asleep and just so happened not to check
on Epstein I find that hard to believe
now you tell me one of them fell asleep
the idea that they both fell asleep is
is difficult to believe so I don't
expect that
this update will do much to quell the
other theories of the case all right
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com his email address this
is from Nick says Matt you are the Fredo
of The Daily wire well you know at least
that means I make it to the end of the
second movie so I'll take it this is
from Ryan says Matt if your take on what
happened with the Cuomo heckler is the
way it actually happened then I agree
with you about defending Cuomo's
reaction however there's a crucial
element to the story I believe you are
overlooking the heckler was an admitted
avid listener to Rush Limbaugh rush has
been calling Chris Cuomo Fredo for years
a term of endearment
as he puts it sure in fact rush
basically never uses Cuomo's real name
him nor does he often explain why he
calls him that the heckler actually
stated in the video that he really
thought Chris chromos name was Fredo I'm
sure you just overlooked that as Cuomo
also did as some sort of BS claim but I
believe there's a high likelihood the
heckler was actually telling the truth
and if that's the case the way this all
started wasn't heckling at all but
simply a guy who saw a famous person and
asked him for a photo together and
called him by the name he genuinely
thought was Cuomo's name if that's the
case the whole thing was just a big
misunderstanding and the heckler was not
really heckling or trolling at all Ryan
I admire your your optimistic view of
this person but I just don't believe for
a second that he really thought the
guy's name was Fredo I don't believe
that for a second everything come on if
you really if the only way he knew about
Chris Cuomo was because he listens to to
Rush Limbaugh how do you know how did he
know what Chris Cuomo looked like if he
knew a Chris Cuomo look like that he
could even pull him out of a crowd with
Cuomo was there he had a hat on him I
don't you know I've seen Chris Cuomo
plenty of times I I'm not even sure that
I would immediately recognize him if he
walked down the street in a ball cap and
maybe I would but if you if you if you
picked him out of the crowd and
recognized them how did you do that if
you've only ever heard his heard him
referred to by by Rush Limbaugh on the
radio that would seem to imply that
you've seen the show
and if you've seen the show you have
seen him identified as Chris Cuomo many
times isn't that even the name of his
show Chris Cuomo live or something like
that maybe this I don't know I don't
really I don't watch it that often but
that's the thing I don't I'm not sitting
around watching Chris Cuomo but I I know
what his name is I know that it's not
Fredo I mean that would be like if you
know there was some celebrity out there
who's who's you know whatever got who
people think resembles Frodo from from
from Lord of the Rings and people called
him Frodo and then you went up to him
and say hey Frodo oh no I thought that
was really your name I'm sorry I thought
your name really I thought your parents
actually named you after the fictional
dwarf from from Lord the Rings I didn't
come on no no I don't believe that for a
second that's that's that's absurd
there's no way again he he would not if
he recognized them it means he's seen
him and if he's seen him he's probably
seen the show and so he's heard Chris
Cuomo not to mention he actually said or
one of the guys in the video said
something like you're much more
reasonable in person than you are on TV
which which what does that tell us
number one he's this is someone who's
seen Chris Cuomo on TV
number two is someone familiar enough
with Chris Cuomo to have it to have this
notion that he's not reasonable number
three this is someone who doesn't like
Chris Cuomo if you think if you think
he's unreasonable you don't even like
him so the idea that he was just a fan
hey let me get a picture with you I'm
yeah I'm just a fan I mean I mean in a
friendly way he insulted him that's
that's an insult oh you're much more
reasonable in person that is cool of
course in insult which would imply that
you're not a big fan of this person but
it's an insult based on apparently your
impression that you've gained from
watching him which means you know his
name so no I don't believe that for a
second he's lying about that and and
which which just makes me want to take
this guy's side even less it this is
this is not about taking Chris Cuomo
side this is about not taking the side
of a trolling heckler who's coming up to
a guy when he's out in public
with his family and and bothering him
and just leave people alone just leave
them alone you don't need to go up to
the guy just ease out with his family
leave but you go up to him where these
with his family and you call him Fredo
and then yeah and then you don't even
have the guts to stand by it and say
yeah I called him Fredo hey this guy's
such a coward you don't eat you don't
even have the guts to stand by what you
said
now you're back it was oh no I really
thought that's what he meant and then he
attacked me Oh boohoo come on man up for
goodness sakes you know what you did at
least admit it no that's that's the
thing people accusing how are you taking
Chris Cuomo side no I'm just not gonna
take I don't take a try chuckling trolls
aside I never ever will I don't care
who's I don't care what their politics
are you go up you're her ass I got in
he's with his wife and you would try to
emasculate him but a frayed oh come here
I take a picture that's obviously an
attempt to emasculate the guy and if you
do that when a guy's with his wife when
he's when he's with his woman you're
gonna get an aggressive response that
any guy would respond that way I mean
any self-respecting guy would would
respond with some level of
aggressiveness not necessarily
physically assaulting him but like if a
guy comes up to you with your wife it
tries to emasculate you um are you just
gonna take it you're just gonna sit
there and say oh gee yeah I'll take a
picture sir you could call me whatever
you want to call me no no no no no no
okay
from Audrey says hey Matt my name is
Audrey long ish time listener I'm in
need of some advice my brothers getting
married soon and we me my five month old
and two year old went to visit him
recently while we were there I asked
about what they planned for family wise
and his fiancee replied having kids is
the worst thing you can do for the
environment i sat there absolutely
dumbfounded while nursing my youngest I
honestly didn't know how to respond to
her any words of advice seeing how this
is a topic that will likely come up
again
Thanks and thanks for all the wonderful
podcasting well okay how would you
respond to that how would I respond I
should you respond I would say smile nod
and slowly back away
you know I well in all seriousness well
that is kind of the right response I
think actually of course if you wanted
to get into a philosophical debate
with your soon-to-be sister-in-law you
could point out that this is this this
view of the human person is grossly
materialistic and reductionist making
people into simple commodities like
vehicles and assessing their impact on
the environment in that way which
doesn't take into account that
transcended aspects of human nature and
of humanity itself things like love and
beauty things that make all life worthy
and and and and worthwhile regardless of
they're supposed to impact on the
environment so you could make that point
if you wanted to but if you don't want
to have a philosophical debate with this
person about their decisions on whether
or not they're gonna have kids then
maybe the best thing is just to say okay
well good for you because really look if
someone doesn't wanna have kids because
they're worried about the environment
then I mean that's their choice and
whatever you know maybe it's best if
they don't if that if their primary
concern is you know co2 levels over
family and kids then that maybe is
someone who's it's best that they don't
anyway have kids so alright somewhat
related question here this is from Sarah
says hi Matt you tend to mock
vegetarianism on your show I wonder if
this is meant as a joke or if you really
find the vegetarian argument absurd I'm
a vegetarian myself and I think you
should take our point of view more
seriously than you do know so it's it's
I don't mean as mockery you know when I
say that vegetarians are communist
sociopathic anti-american lunatics
that's not an insult you say I don't
mean as an insult fact I mean it as a
compliment
no I know I don't really think that
about vegetarians that is a joke here's
what I'll say about the veg and when you
say the vegetarian argument I assume you
mean the moral argument because there
are two parts of it right there's the
moral argument there are people who are
vegetarian because they think it's wrong
to kill animals and then there are
people are vegetarian because they think
is the healthiest thing and then I'm
sure there's a lot of crossover there
but I'm not gonna address the health
aspect of it
the moral aspect here's what I'll say no
I don't think in all seriousness I don't
think that the vegetarian moral argument
is crazy or absurd of course it's not
absurd it would be absurd to say that
it's absurd now I don't agree with it
obviously because otherwise I'd be
vegetarian but it's not absurd your
point is that you'll animals are human
or not human animals are our life and so
- they are complex life and so to you
know take a life like that when when
when you have other options and you
could live without it as many people do
is wrong that's basically your argument
right and I think that that's a
perfectly reasonable argument so that's
my that's my answer to that what I would
say though in response is it seems clear
to me that human beings are meant to
have animals as part of their diet just
as many other animals have animals as
part of their diet
now it doesn't really matter how you
approach this if you if you're if you
believe in God and if you are a follower
of the judeo-christian tradition then
you could point to the Bible and you can
see it clearly we were given domain over
the animals and the plants and and and
so that gives us the not the license to
abuse animals or to be cruel but
certainly to use them in a certain way
including for fuel for for ourselves
biological fuel or if you let's say are
not a theist and you approach from a
secular evolutionary perspective then
it's even more the case that it's clear
that we evolved to eat other animals as
omnivores just like in their plenty
other animals the animal kingdom to do
as well and so we're no different from
them either way I don't see how yeah I
think the absolute moral the absolutist
moral argument vegetarians make although
it's not absurd there is a certain sense
to it I don't agree with it for that
reason it's just clear to me whether
you're coming from a the--let theistic
theological perspective or just a
biological evolutionary perspective
either way it seems clear to me that we
were meant to eat animals now on the
other hand if you want to get into
talking about factory farming and how we
just produce animals now by the billions
simply to eat them and we have them
locked in these tiny little cages and
they live lives of suffering and misery
and just utterly pointless and they're
only there to be eaten and you know you
look at how animals are treated in the
factory farming environment now there I
think you have a very very good case in
fact I really even though I eat food I
readily admit that I eat food that is
produced by factory farming I I couldn't
make a moral argument to vindicate
factory farming I don't I don't see how
anyone could it's I mean it's pretty
clear that animals in that environment
are it's it's this is cruel and not
right to treat animals that way because
it's just a total disregard now I I do
believe there's a hierarchy here and
human life is more important than animal
life but we can't say that animal life
is utterly meaningless and it has no
value at all but in the factory farming
environment they are their lives are
treated as totally meaningless no point
at all except to be eaten by us and that
their own you know experience is is
completely irrelevant and there's a
complete disregard for that and I think
that that's wrong so yeah I continue to
eat that food does that make me a
hypocrite yes it does all right let's
see this is from Mark says Matt I was
having this discussion with a friend and
thought you'd maybe have something
interesting to say about it what is a
genius how would you define the word
genius well first of all mark I love
that you're sitting around your friends
having an abstract discussion like that
which I which is much better than small
talk in my view I think that's great
what is a genius that is an interesting
you know I think well I think age
is not simply someone who has a high IQ
I think that IQ tests do tell us
something it's probably unlikely that a
person would get say a 50 on an IQ test
and yet be a genius
so I think IQ tests do measure something
but I don't think they get the whole
story and of course being a genius also
has really almost nothing to do with
what how much stuff you know you know
what kind of what information you have
in your head that has nothing to do with
genius whatsoever there could be there
could be there can be probably are and
certainly have been geniuses across the
world who knew very little just because
they had little access to information so
knowing something just what that
reflects is how much information you
have access to we live in a culture
today where we all know a lot of stuff
our knowledge doesn't go very deep but
we have access to a ton of information
so we're ingesting information all the
time
yet most of us are certainly not
geniuses and in fact I think there are
quite a lot of very stupid people in the
modern Western world stupid people who
know a lot of stuff just because they
can't help but know it so those things
have nothing to do a genius I think that
um genius really is someone who doesn't
take his reality for granted I think if
you if you had to really find what's the
common thread between all the great
geniuses of history these are people who
don't take their reality for granted
what I mean is a genius of someone who
doesn't just passively accept everything
that's told to him he doesn't just
accept things as they are presented a
genius truly appreciates what is really
remarkable in the world doesn't take
that for granted and has an ability to
think beyond our current reality has an
ability to think in revolutionary terms
that to me is a genius so we could see
this for example in music what's the
difference between a really talented
musician and a musical genius are they
the same no I don't think so I think
there are a lot of talented musicians
who aren't geniuses but guys like Elvis
Presley Bob Dylan you know even Kurt
Cobain and Tupac I mean these these were
geniuses because they changed music
because they were able to see something
they were able to do something different
with it they did
get for granted they were able to go in
a different direction I think that I'm
trying to avoid the outside-the-box
thinking cliche but that's basically
what I'm talking about here
Einstein was obviously a genius Newton
was a genius da Vinci was the Jews these
were men who were beyond smart I mean
they just they thought about the world
differently and they changed the world
because of it
Einstein with his relativity theory he
he just thought of that
that was the crazy thing about Einstein
is that he he he wasn't he was building
on prior research and things too but
more than that it was just it was just
pure thought he just came up with things
about the world by thinking about them
and and changed our view of the world
immeasurably through his own thoughts
that is genius so that's what I think
it's what genius
hey I mean if you think about it every
smart person you know maybe not all
historic geniuses but certainly the
people who are maybe minor geniuses or
at least intellectually gifted one of
the main ways that you know they're very
smart is that they're they're able to
say things or present things that make
you go oh man I never thought of it that
way
I think that's the mark of at least an
intellectually gifted person if they
have the ability with whatever they're
doing or saying whatever the presenter
whatever idea they're presenting to you
if they have this ability to make you go
I just never thought of it like that
when you read a book from an author and
you think wow that's an interesting way
of thinking of it I never thought of it
that way in fact I'm reading a book now
not I don't know what I did with it it's
a it's down there it's a book called
sapiens by Hans like I forget the guys
name a book called sapiens by you've all
Noah Harare and I pick us up at the
airport and I'm almost through it I
think that I'm not gonna call it a work
of genius and the thing is I disagree
profoundly with a lot of the stuff in
that in the book that I'm reading now
which is kind of supposed to be a
history of humankind going from you know
from
primitive days - - today I disagree
profoundly with a lot of it and this is
someone who would certainly
anti-religion for one thing and that
becomes very clear but there are some
sort of genius elements of it because
there are because in the book he for
instance a lot of the book is basically
a almost a polemic against the
agricultural revolution which is so I'm
reading that it was I don't really agree
you know I think the agricultural
revolution ten thousand years ago was a
good thing and it made human
civilization possible which is no sum no
small perk either but I don't think I've
ever heard anyone actually criticized
the Agricultural Revolution that's just
something we all take for granted well
yeah agriculture of course that's good
we need that so in this book at least
through part of it he he's basically
arguing that we'd be better if it never
happened in giving his reasons again I
don't agree with all the reasons but I
think that's sort of a a genius move in
a way be able to take something that
everyone else takes for granted make
some observations about it that other
people hadn't thought of and then make
people go oh but I just hadn't thought
of it that way
alright so we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching Godspeed in the
wake of Fredo Cuomo's meltdown many
prominent conservatives are taking CNN
side and President Trump is furious
about that
then another CNN scandal this time
involving Don Lemon and it takes place
at one of my favorite bars in New York
we'll go into that an evangelical
musician loses his faith and finally
more details emerge in the Jeffrey
Epstein saga check it out on a Michael
Knowles show